so can we actually thinking about uh
star field thinking about Elder Scroll 6
go through the full life of a video game
you've created so what's it take to take
a game
from the idea to find the final product
what are the different steps along the
way
great question
um well usually it starts with I mean
honestly lunchtime conversations with a
number of us hey we we think we want to
do this this is what it's going to be
like I mean look with an Elder Scrolls
you know you're gonna do it
it's a matter of when you say okay
what's the tone we're going for right
where is it set so we usually start with
the world
and then
we're always overlapping so while we're
making one game as we're you know
getting in the throes of it or wrapping
it up you know probably by the midpoint
of one game we've had enough
conversations
to understand what the next one's going
to be what are the big ticket like
where's it set what's the tone is there
a big ticket feature or two that make it
really unique
and then when we're finishing one game
we start
um
prototyping sorry before that we start
concepting so we'll do concept art
and for one reason or another I usually
have the beginning of the game worked
out like I like to think about okay
how's the game start what's the player
do first
We Do music early
you know so take Elder Scrolls six we
figure out where it's set what's the
tone what are the big features we
discussed the beginning of the game
which we've had for a very long time
where's this set again
um yep uh in Tamriel and
uh damn it well at least we know we
narrowed it down that yeah that would be
epic if it was like a portal into
another dimension anyway then I like to
do music so we've already done a take on
the music for Elder Scrolls six so you
can sit there with the with like the the
concept art and the music no no the
music we put in the teaser for it this
was 2018.
um we've taken that further obviously
and
again we're working on the world you're
then doing concepting and design for the
world and then once we we're wrapping up
one game we can really start prototyping
the new one and you're usually building
kind of your initial spaces and so we do
like to do like a first playable a
smaller section of the game
that we can sort of prove out show to
people hey this is how it feels
different this is what it looks like
this is what's unique about it then we
turn that into a larger chunk when more
of the team comes on when the other game
is done
um and that's still what we call a vs
vertical slice so you still don't have
the full team on it
and it's a larger chunk of the game that
you can play and then once you feel good
about that you're going to bring on
the rest of the team
and we're fortunate that the other games
we've done are popular enough that we
can be doing DLC and content and those
kind of things while we're getting the
one going and then we're at full
production
where we're sort of at maximum size we
just call that production that's like
the full production period
and that depending on the game
you know can run a year two years maybe
more
and then you kind of have a finalizing
final six months to a year on a game
which is okay we've built everything now
um
and usually it needs a lot of glue where
we have a lot of
very different elements that maybe
aren't clicking together the way you
want outside of the regular polish for
levels and features
and we're shaving and gluing and
sticking things together so that it's
not the schizophrenic game experience
that things flow from one end to another
in terms of story like on that level
it's really no usually the story The
designers have done a really good job
it's more about game features you know
and then how they interact with the
story or hey I went from this experience
to this experience or picking flowers
and Alchemy feels like a different game
than and then how is another character
referencing that and how is that
intersecting with
the skill system and the interface like
the skill system and the interface is
the party host
if you think about a game most games
particularly what I like to do
is that's your person that says welcome
do this go here check this out and the
skill system and the way it reacts on
the HUD the interface of the game is
sort of leading you to the next thing in
it and once you get that flow down
and the the
rate at which the game is giving you
activities then you're in like what we
we describe as a game Flow what is and
it's not until really that last year
before that the game Flow was just it's
not it doesn't even exist
in the way that you see it in the final
game
and that's what we're working on a lot
that last year
so at which point is like the set of
skills a skill tree
the characteristics of the role-playing
aspect of it when is that set the idea
is we usually have it in the beginning
but it's just we know it won't be done
until that last year we'll have one but
we know it's going to get honed
because it's not until you really see
okay how impactful is that one how much
are you doing it like how much are you
really and the main combat ones they
always win you always know the players
will drift toward the combat type skills
because every character needs some
amount of that but okay well how how
important is cooking how important is
alchemy how important
is these other type of activities and
then how do you balance them where when
you load up the skill menu it isn't
automatically give me plus 10 damage
how do you get the what about the combat
system that does seem to be an important
part of a lot of games you started in
the beginning yeah every time yep
so usually we're making that first
playable it's an area you can go through
some amount of dialogue some out of
combat
how do you get the combat right what's
the secret to a great combat system
well first on a control side helping the
player when they don't realize it
there's a lot of tricks you can do with
magnetism in terms of the controller and
where the attacks go so it has to feel
the minute to minute has to feel really
good in your hands there's a lot of
Animation time
right and changing animations so they're
impactful and they they happen at a rate
that the player feels
like they're really doing it and then
ultimately it's the illusion that the
enemies are smart
but they really
are there for you to kill them right so
they do a lot of things to just let
themselves get killed they're not a near
Smart near smart as we can make them
because it turns out that is not fun
foreign
so there's a balance between but there's
a that is I guess a kind of AI
and
it's a very intimate interaction with an
AI because it's like there's a lot of
stuff going on it's not just
very kind of shallow like a dialogue or
something like that it's like
there's a Time critical nature of it a
lot of stuff is happening and if ever if
anything feels off it's it's gonna feel
it wrong yep all the games Do It
um you know it's not unique to what we
do in terms of how they handle combat
scenarios and there's some games that
just do it extremely well in terms of
um even in multiplayer where you're
playing Bots and most people don't know
it
um or how
a multiple enemy scenario is really you
know they don't all shoot you they trade
off they're gonna wait and I was like
I'll just wait my turn because we don't
want to overwhelm them but he feels like
you feel like you're overwhelmed when
there's six enemies but
you know a good game will no they're
gonna they're gonna take their time
is there a science to it is it is it art
is it like
oh my God yes yes I mean it's it's all
of that so it's like an iterative
process where you try different things
there's a lot of there's a lot of
Animation there's a lot of timing
animation work
hard work also how does the reticule
change
um what are the little sound effects
what about like the the gamify like that
is fun
that again that goes back to the winning
you know the winning is fun yes death
does not yes Let The Wookie win
I like how you have to dumb down the AI
to make it fun for humans
um because if if you didn't it would
just be just Slaughter non-stop for for
All Humans that's good to know what
about things like
um
he said cooking like crafting making
potions and poisons and uh smithing
weapons and armor cooking how do you get
that right what's what's interesting
there such an interesting like
uh just you know a lot of games don't
have that kind of thing so what role
does that play you know you know I think
we really cracked it in a way I like
with Fallout 4 actually where when we're
doing Elder Scrolls we have like the
flowers and things and you have Alchemy
and we took this to okay if it's
post-apocalyptic what if everything in
the world
was an alchemical ingredient sometimes
so breaking it down to their components
so when you walk around a world like
that again we like the simulation we
like we like the forks and spoons and
the cups and all that okay how can I use
those to create so I love how it works
starts working in Fallout 4 where okay
all these things I find there is they
have some value
in creating or crafting outside of a cup
is worth one gold piece or one cap